hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast expansion of human stem cells
in bio blue single-use vessels from
Eppendorf I am julie O'Rourke of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's webcast is
presented by labyrinth comm the leading
social media site for science
professional and sponsored by eppendorf
Eppendorf is a leading life science
company that develops themselves
instruments consumables and services for
liquid sample and cell handling in
laboratories worldwide for more
information please visit Eppendorf com
before we start there are a few
instructions this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CTE button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits we want
to hear from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us a comment
answers are welcome to you can do this
by hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can then we'll follow up if you don't
have time today
want a better look you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear or
see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
on the top right or use the Q&A button
we'll make sure we try to resolve any
issues now let's get right to today's
presenter we are proud to welcome Stacy
Willard PhD a senior technical
application specialist in bioprocess at
Eppendorf dr. Willard earned a PhD from
the University of Virginia and has more
than 15 years experience in cell culture
applications in both academia and
industry after completing postdoctoral
work at Johns Hopkins Medical School she
spent time in a start of drug discovery
company and at a large Cancer Institute
before joining Eppendorf as part of the
global bio process applications team at
Eppendorf dr. Willard specializes in
high-level problem solving for customers
training and product development I will
now hand the presentation over to dr.
Willard thank you very much for that
excellent introduction
I'm happy to be here today and for the
opportunity to share with you an update
on what Eppendorf has been doing with
the expansion of stem cells and single
youth bio reactors the title of my talk
today is expansion of human stem cells
an Eppendorf bio blue single-use vessel
and it's a true collaboration between a
couple of our applications laboratories
at Eppendorf you'll notice in the byline
here there's a laboratory here in
Connecticut and Enfield Connecticut in
the United States we also have a
laboratory in Belgium and we have
another very close collaborator at
Hanover Medical School and the data I'm
going to present today is attributed to
you all three of these laboratories so
today we're going to talk a little bit
about stem cells in general human stem
cells in particular the different types
where they come from and what they're
used for in the clinical application
will tell you a little bit about what
we've done and how we've done it talk
about our results and some conclusions
and future work that can be done in this
area and let's concern jump right into
it so human stem cells this will be a
bit of a review for some of you but some
of you might be new to this stem cell
field so I wanted to take a moment to
make sure we're all on the same page
with some definitions stem cells are
cells that are capable of self-renewal
and daughter cell generation for long
periods you can see in the little
diagram on the slide here that a stem
cell will divide creating a daughter
cell that can differentiate or
specialized into a cell type a different
cell type and then it will also create
another one of itself and that's the
self renewal process it maintains its
ability to divide over and over again
for a long period of time the stem cell
itself is undifferentiated which means
its unspecialized so it doesn't have a
lot of those characteristics that we
attribute to things like a neuron or a
liver cell or something like that they
are generally
non-specialized cells but they can give
rise to specialized cell types and
sometimes that means that there's a
middleman so their daughter cell can be
something like a transit amplifying cell
or a middle stem cell type that can
still give rise to other cell types etc
so to be classified in the stem cell you
can break them down into three different
categories
Cody potent which is a stem cell that
can give rise to any cell type including
part of the part of the placenta and
other embryonic tissues pluripotent
which is one that can give rise to many
cell types all of the different germ
layers of the embryo in fact and
multipotent which can give rise to
several cell types with but not usually
all different cell types in the embryo
so stem cells can be classified in those
three ways and you'll hear me use these
different potency terms throughout the
presentation so I wanted to make sure we
were all on the same page in terms of
what those words meant moving on
so stem cells for research purposes can
be broadly characterized into three
types and this is all to do with where
they come from so as you can imagine
embryonic stem cells are pluripotent
issue types in the embryo adult stem
cells coming from adult tissues are
usually multipotent so they cannot give
rise to every single cell type in the
embryo but they can become multiple cell
types if they're induced to
differentiate or specialize and then
third induced pluripotent stem cells are
actually somatic or regular adult body
cells that are reprogrammed to become
pluripotent or have the potential to
become any embryonic cell type so in
this presentation today we're not going
to talk about embryonic stem cells we're
going to focus in on the adult stem cell
population and the induced pluripotent
stem cell population and we've been
doing a lot of work at Eppendorf in
terms of trying to create large numbers
of these cells for research purposes and
so that's what we'll focus on today
so one of these adult stem cell types
are human mesenchymal stem cells or H
MSC s ms these are adult stem cells of
stromal origin so they come from
connective tissues of cells of any organ
examples are the uterine mucosa the
prostate stroma the bone marrow adipose
tissues ovary many different cell types
have been used to derive mizenko mul
stem cells and the different types of
stem cells can then be induced to
differentiate into other cell types and
the number of types of cells they can
become is determined by their tissue of
origin so these stem cells MSC's in
particular are involved in a large
number of clinical trials in fact
there's several that are already in
phase 3 stage and there are actually
already drug in quotes on the market
because they are actually cellular
therapy products they're being
manufactured in korea they're being used
for treatment in the field already so
this is a field that has great hope and
great promise for disease treatment you
can see here if you just go to clinical
trials.gov that there's over 600 trials
in the USA alone involving missing komal
stem cells and that's just in the u.s.
you can imagine if you total up
everything globally that there are
probably thousands of clinical trials
going on right now involving these stem
cells so in since maybe the year 2000
this field has just exploded in terms of
interest so what can mesenchymal stem
cells become and what is their potential
for disease treatment if you look at
this diagram here you can see them as
Mykel stem cell in the middle and you
can see all the different types of cells
that that have been a subset of what's
been done so far so they can be used to
generate myocytes or muscle tissue skin
cells fibroblasts central nervous system
neurons like astrocytes and other cell
types stromal cells from the bone marrow
fat cells or a dip aside
cells that make up tendons and ligaments
different specialized fibroblasts and
then of course osteocytes in bone so
many many different cell types have
already been derived from these adult
stem cells EMS ES and I'm sure you could
imagine that the potential clinical
application of these cells is is quite
huge and varied here's a nice diagram
showing you some of the potential
disease treatments for things like
baldness blindness deafness ALS
myocardial infarction muscular dystrophy
I won't mention all of them as you can
see them here and so the Hult on this on
this whole field in general are quite
high so the other type of stem cell
we're going to focus on today is the
human induced pluripotent stem cell
again can be can be used for cellular
therapy and disease modeling but their
origin is quite different than the
mesenchymal stem cell population so the
age I P SCS are actually reprogrammed
from adult samples these can be things
like a biopsy or a blood sample and then
they can be after they're reprogrammed
for pluripotency they can be
differentiated into multiple cell types
so if you look at this diagram here what
you can see is we have this human in the
middle here a healthy or diseased
individual and then a sample is taken
from that individual by a biopsy via a
blood sample etc and the somatic cells
are grown from that sample so this can
be done as you can imagine autologous
lee so a sample from the affected
patient can be taken somatic cells can
be grown from that patient sample and
then using any of these techniques that
are outlined up above here you can see
that we can force expression of genes
that will induce pluripotent nature in
these cells those things like using a
virus to express protein using a plasma
to force expression of approaching
protein transduction itself mi RNA small
molecules all of these things have been
shown to be used in reprogramming the
cells to become pluripotent whereas they
weren't before so in the dish here what
you end up with is a human induced
pluripotent cell line here in the in the
petri dish here and then of course using
these cells you can then initiate
differentiation in two cell types that
you find in the embryo after Derby
syndrome and endoderm and many many cell
types have been catalyzed so far as
possible and potential from the IPS see
population so a little bit about the
field of IPS see IPS see reprogramming
has been something that come up pretty
recently in the stem cell field the
seminal work being publication by the
Yamanaka group where human for skin
fibroblasts were forced to over express
a list of factors called the Yamanaka
factors and those included are CH 3 for
Sox 2 klf4
and C mech an expression of this
combination of factors imparted
pluripotency to these normal just
everyday fibroblasts and that was a
pretty seminal finding and then
selection of those reprogrammed clones
resulted in populations that can express
other employee potency markers such as
at 78 for trial 160 and there's quite a
few others but I'm I'm of course
purposely calling out these because
we're going to talk about them later in
the presentation
so the reprogrammed cells can then be
induced to differentiate into other
specialized cell types so once you
express the Yamanaka factors you show
that the cells are pluripotent you can
then buy a different combination of
treatment of media etc you can get them
to differentiate it to specialized cell
types such as cardiomyocytes
some of you might have tuned in to
another recent stem cell webinar by
Eppendorf where our close colleague at
Rutgers Rick Cohen took some
reprogrammed IPS see cell lines and made
cardiomyocytes from them make dopamine
neurons from them and so we've shown
that in quite a few different ways that
could get many different specialized
cell types from these real
pre-programmed cells and so I'm sure you
can imagine the potential of a dish of
cardio myocyte
dopamine neurons insulin producing cells
and these cells will then express
factors that relate to their identity
such as a cardio myocyte will will
express a cardio myocyte specific marker
and you can use that to follow their
reprogram ability or differentiation
ability so that was by way of an
introduction to the field and what's
been going on there and the stage that
we're at now in the field is that
producing a critical mass of stem cells
has been very challenging for example
spontaneous differentiation is a problem
in the culture aggregation of the cells
some cell lines like aggregation some
cell lines don't and we have had a few
that have had detrimental effects
because of that aggregation pH and
oxygen sensitivity we have to be very
careful about what the pH is in the
culture and the sensitivity of the cells
to do or dissolve oxygen and and then
also they're very sensitive to shear
forces so they if we stir too fast or or
sparge into many bubbles into the
culture sometimes that can cause
detrimental effects such as
differentiation and loss of cell growth
so the final expanded population of stem
cells the MSD and IPSC should have the
following characteristics and this is
going to be a very important point that
we're going to come and refer back to
you throughout the whole rest of the
presentation so take a minute to make
sure that we're all clear on this so the
large cell numbers is the first thing
we're after here as I'm sure you can
imagine if you're going to do autologous
cellular therapy you need a very large
number of cells to be able to
differentiate into enough cells to treat
a patient with the cells must retain
their pluriel multi potency so they must
be able to continue on and retain the
markers that make that stem cells as
opposed to all differentiating
to daughter cell and going off down the
line of differentiation and then third
the cell must retain the ability to
differentiate into the desired cell type
so even if you have a multipotent cell
line that has large cell numbers if it
can't become the cell that you want it
to become then that becomes not not what
we're looking for
so the follows the three characteristics
that I've outlined here we're going to
keep coming back to because I'm going to
show you in the rest of the pot the
presentation and the rest of the work
that we have actually accomplished these
three goals for multiple different cell
types and multiple scales
so here I'm showing you a summary or an
illustration of what I'm about to tell
you in the rest of the presentation so
to illustrate the process of scaling up
cell culture in bio blue single-use
vessels we use two different MSD cell
lines and some each IPSC cell lines in
bio blue single-use vessels using both
the dock box and the New Brunswick's
telogen blue bio process control station
so what you can see on the top here is
at the small scale we've used
cultivation of MSC s on micro carriers
at the 250 mil volume so that's this one
up here you can see this bioreactor is
much smaller and we can show that we
generate large cell numbers we retain
stem cell markers and we can still
differentiate into specialized cell
types and then similarly we can scale up
to the bio blue 5c which is a maximum
working volume of 3.75 liters and then
in this case also we can get large cell
numbers in fact up to a billion stem
cells in one batch stem cell markers and
are retained and cells are still able to
differentiate into multiple cell types
so we've done quite a bit of work on MSC
s in the past and if you're interested
in the detail
I won't I can't go into the detail on
every single bioreactor and all of the
set points in this presentation or I
would run out of time quite quickly but
if you'd like to you can look at our
pubs our publications that are all
available and linked here on the on the
forum somewhere and then we'll switch
gears and we'll talk about the
cultivation of induced pluripotent stem
cells so at this we've done quite a bit
of work with our collaborators and
that's a Hanover medical school and also
in our lab here at Enfield with IPS C at
the small scale so we're talking about
the small bio blue 3.3 C bioreactor or
the mini bioreactor and a maximum
working volume of 250 milliliters and
again we can show that we get expansion
of cell numbers we retain cell markers
and we are still able to differentiate
into different
types so that's a high-level summary of
what we're going to talk about for the
rest of the presentation and as soon as
I load up here we are ready to move on
to the materials and methods so as I
said I won't go over every single tiny
detail about every bioreactor because it
would take me hours but I will talk
generally about the control stations so
in the small-scale work we use the
dosbox mini bioreactor system and the
greatest feature about this system is
that it is a truly parallel process
development vehicle it allows the OE
capability it has up you can run up to
24 of these point 3 liter vessels
simultaneously and in a truly parallel
manner so it has a very powerful
platform and then when you get to the
larger scale the bench scale something
like the 5 liter stirred tank you can
move on to many of our controllers which
are compatible with the bio blue
single-use vessel including what we use
for our study which was this elegant
blue bench top bioreactor we can combine
the single-use technology of the bio
blue vessel with the already tried and
true performance of the traditional
stirred tank design making that quite a
powerful combination as well so the
vessels the vessels the bio blue
single-use vessel line are available all
the way from the three hundred
milliliter scale all the way up to the
50 liter scale making it quite a perfect
scale up for stem cell work they are
rigid wall stir tank bio reactors they
have a pitch blade impeller they are USP
Class six an animal component free so
they're appropriate for GMP production
and of course their proven scalability
so you can scale up from all the way
from the point three all the way up to
the 50 see also I should mention that
the one liter scale and greater they are
compatible multiple of our control
stations so that's a really nice feature
as well I get a lot of questions in when
I talk about the bio blue single-use
vessels about leachable and there's a
lot of data that that that we
have on the plastics but we can also
show you these data which is where we've
done an extraction on the plastic in the
vessel itself at 37 degrees for three
days and then we've grown show cells in
that extracted media to show that in
fact there's no effect detrimental
effect on growth of the cells due to
anything coming out of the plastic into
the medium at 37 degrees so you can see
here in this graph what we're showing is
many of the different sizes and vessels
were tested and so the media was left in
the vessel at 37 degrees for three days
and then show cells were inoculated
internet media and we saw no detrimental
effect and you can see all the way out
here on growth based on this this
extracted media so this is just a we're
going to show you a little summary of
the different cell lines and medium that
we used in the studies if you're working
on stem cells right now then you're very
familiar with the fact that every single
one of these cell lines is a bit
different they all have their own
personality based on where they came
from and they are all leading
optimization in the particular
laboratory so at anytime you probably
are not going to be able to just order
one of these cell lines and immediately
get it to grow there will definitely be
a little bit of a learning curve with
stem cells and I'm sure all of the stem
cell biologists in the audience are
nodding their heads going yeah yeah we
always have to take a lot of
optimization on these cell lines so for
our adipose derived stem cell work we
retain we took our stem cell source at
HEC C we used a TCC's medium kit for
growing those cells as for their growth
support or type both MSC cell lines
require micro carrier so in fact for the
adipose derived mesenchymal stem cell
work we got our micro carrier from tall
corporation and some were college
encoded and some were not you'll see we
got better results using collagen coated
micro carrier and then for the bone
marrow MSC
you can see that we got our stem cell
from Lanza we use the logs of bullet kit
for medium and similar to the other MSC
cell line they are Anchorage dependent
and so they grow on micro carrier and we
grew them on GE healthcare sided X micro
carrier and then for the IPS see work
their work that we did involve a cell
line that was derived at the Medical
Center in Hanover and then there was an
another cell line that we got here in
the u.s. from the ATCC
both work involved stem cell
technologies teaser line of media either
em teaser or two either eight and they
were grown either in free aggregates
without micro carrier or we also did
some work using micro carrier and the
micro carrier that we use for that work
was Paul corporations collagen coded
micro carrier I'll tell you a little bit
more in subsequent slides what I mean by
growing in aggregates but the difference
between an MSc cell line usually and an
IPS C cell line is that the IPS C cells
tend to like to form clumps they like to
be in aggregate and you can actually get
them to grow in very large cell numbers
by maintaining that aggregation on
purpose so we'll talk more about that
later and again as I said all the set
points inoculation density is all of
that information that you're looking for
can be found in the related publications
that you can see linked under the links
section and you can also ask us for them
more happy to send you out some links
via email as well if you reach out to us
so let's get into the results first
let's talk about the MFC cell so for the
adipose direct MSC's or the ad MSC s
there was a very interesting finding on
inoculum prep early preparation actually
when we first started to grow the cells
we saw that the field had classically
grown them in spinner flasks and a
standard co2 incubator but we weren't
getting great results using that format
so we decided to switch over and grow
them in single-use Erlenmeyer shake
flasks on it and on the shaking co2
incubator you can find this work
previously published in the bio
processing journal
and basically we've developed a novel
method using shake flats instead of
spinner flats using the New Brunswick
s41 I co2 incubator shaker the reason
why this is my favorites of the
incubator line is that it has can go
very low speed shaking so you don't have
a shear force problem in your culture
you don't really need to use clamps if
you don't so desire you can use the
proprietary ste pads that we have
available and also you can put a static
shelf in this incubator as well so you
can go all the way from your tee blaq
into your shake flask can start your
scale up all in the same incubator so
that's a pretty powerful
platform there you can go all the way up
to a maximum of two liter volume using
ten one liter shake flask and of course
the advantage is that you don't have to
put a magnetic stirrer plate inside the
incubator and generate extra heat that
the incubator has to then deal with and
when it's trying to do temperature
control and of course logistically it's
very simple and large capacity to just
use a shaker platform so it ended up
being a very useful novel method for
making the inoculant
and just to show you a little bit of
data on why we think the shakes last
method is a little bit better for this
particular cell line if you look at this
graph here what you can see is that in
the shake flask in blue we got a much
higher total cell number over time than
we did with the spinner and we wanted to
know why that was so if you do a little
further investigation what you can see
is the concentration of glucose and
ammonia are correlating with that
increased growth so you see here the
concentration of glucose and the spinner
flask is going down much slower than it
is in the shake flask which is what
correlates with the faster growth rate
that we got in the shake flask and then
of course the concentration of ammonia
builds up faster in the spinner flask
and ammonia is known to be toxic
especially to a sensitive cell line like
a stem cell line so this was sort of not
unexpected but a good good way to show
that this method was definitely the way
to go so once we got enough inoculum to
go into the buyer
actor at the larger scale we went ahead
to inoculate a bio blue 5c single-use
vessel using collagen coded micro
carrier beads and this was actually done
using only overlay do control at a low
do set point so this was trying to mimic
a hypoxic condition and our cell density
reached four times 10 to the fifth cells
per milliliter which actually ended up
being 1.5 billion cells in one single
batch run so this was actually quite a
successful experiment and our glucose
and lactate concentrations over time
matched what you would expect from this
method so glucose went down over time
what you can see from the second graph
here is that every time glucose is
peaking that's happening because we're
changing media so every couple of days
we would let the micro carrier settle
remove some of the spent media and in
fresh media and this allowed us to do
great pH control and allowed us to
really provide the nutrients that these
cells needed to reach such high density
so we can show now the data from doing
this in point three C and five C scale
in both scales why are cell numbers were
achieved so if you are interested in
starting at the small stage before you
scale up to the five C the point 3 C is
very successful in growing missyjoymel
stem cells as well if you compare the
two methods here in this slide you can
see that we reach very similar densities
using the point 3 C single-use vessel as
we did with the 5 C single-use vessel
we're also showing you here that we can
have this similar excellent growth
profile in adipose derived stem cells
and bone marrow drive stem cells so this
is not just a one cell line in
particular method this works for
multiple cell lines and multiple scales
which is a really nice robust method
so the first order of business was to
make a lot of cells and we've shown you
that we can do that using the bio blue
single-use vessel but making a lot of
cells is really only valuable if they
are still stem cells so what we can show
here is that we're satisfying that
second of the of the rules that I
presented to you in the beginning cells
are retaining their multi potency marker
expression and the markers that we've
chosen to identify here with the at MSC
line are cd44 in green and the best way
to be able to see this is to look at the
micro carrier bridging here so this is
actually cells between the micro carrier
so let me just circle it here so it's
nice and clear for you right here you
can see the cell bridging across two
very large micro carriers and you can
see that they are green expressing the
cd44 stem cell marker and then if you
look in the next panel you can see again
on one of the micro carrier bridges here
you can see the red expression of
seeding 90 so you can see that after
expansion in the bio blue 5c they are
still retaining their their stem cell
markers just in case that wasn't
quantitative or clear enough for you we
also went ahead and confirmed these
results by PCR analysis and so here
we're looking at markers similar to what
I mentioned in the beginning of the
presentation so we have ox 3 4 we've got
socks to expression we have beta actin
as our control we have CD 105 we have CD
44 and then as our negative control we
have CD 45 and so what you can see from
these graphs are these gel pictures is
that in lane 1 we have a positive
control so you should see a positive in
each one of lane 1 Lane 2 is our
negative controls you shouldn't see
anything in Lane 2
then three four five and six are samples
taken at various times throughout the
bioreactor Rock and you can see that
they are retaining the expression of the
multi potency markers like they are
supposed to so they are getting large
cell numbers they are retaining their
pluripotent markers their multi potency
markers and now we need to know whether
they are still able to differentiate
into the specialized cell type that
we're interested in so we're going to
show two examples here the first is the
bone marrow derived stem cells
cultivated in the bio blue 0.3 C
single-use vessel and we're showing you
that we've successfully differentiated
those cells into osteogenic lineage
which you can see on the right side of
this slide here is Eleazar at red s
staining so that shows you calcium
deposition and calcium deposition is of
course a marker for osteogenic lineage
and then you can see this quantitation
using the osteo image mineralization
athing showing that the non induced
versus induced is a huge difference so
over time you get more and more
differentiation into this osteogenic
lineage moving on to the the adipose
drive mesenchymal stem cells we've
differentiated these cells from the
biobus IC into n dip and dip sites and
osteocytes adipocytes being ones that
will create less lipid droplets which is
what you can see in panel a here by the
red oil o oil red o staining and then in
panel B you can also see the Eleazar and
red s staining which is indicative of
calcium mineralization or osteocyte
osteogenic Lanier's lineage so in fact
these cells are able to differentiate
into specific cell types that we are
asking them to differentiate into so
what about the IPS see the induced
pluripotent stem cells and these are a
very different cell line to handle I
want to show you a little bit more about
that aggregate formation technique that
I mentioned in the beginning of the
presentation so IPS C's can be grown
either on micro carrier or in
and we're actually developing both
applications at Eppendorf and to spend
most of my time talking to you about the
data that was kindly provided by our
collaborator at in Hannover Medical
School four-fold expansion in his lab
was achieved of age IPS sees as
aggregates in a stirred tank batch
format and you'll notice I have this
word batch and quotes I'll tell you why
that is in a minute in the future slide
IPSC is incredibly sensitive to pH and
to do and to shear into these other
types of issues and the batch in quotes
is indicating the fact that daily we
allow the aggregates to settle and
replenish the media with fresh media to
make sure that everything is exactly the
way the cell lines require so what you
can see in this picture here is you can
see that in the beginning when we first
start on day 0 the cells are single
cells and you can go ahead and zoom in
on this if you'd like on your screen or
look at it later and you can maybe blow
it up and see the single cells there and
then they start to form aggregates as
time goes on and those aggregates get
larger and larger until you have update
7 a field full of very large spheres
here and they can get quite large they
can get over 300 microns in diameter in
our lab we jokingly refer to them as
meatballs at that stage because they
just look so humongous in that in the
microscope and of course as the
aggregate gets larger the inside of the
aggregate starts to have issues like
differentiation restriction of nutrients
and and there start to be less healthy
so there is a upper limit to what you
want to get let those aggregates get to
be in terms of size so what the group
and Hannover has done quite successfully
is shown that in the bio blue point 3 C
stage you can get expansion of IPSC as
aggregates in this quote-unquote batch
format and so we're it's not it's a bit
bit more like halfway between a badge
and a FET
at this point so we are beating the sell
we are replenishing some of the media
but it's not quite at something that you
would call a profusion because it's
being done in a Bullis way once a day
and you can check out these graphs here
these show you all the different types
of metabolic profile that we have and
you can see the cells grow quite nicely
glucose concentration goes up each time
the media is replenished and then pH of
course changes every time the media is
changed as well interestingly this group
has also developed a quote-unquote
perfusion method as well and so what
this means is that they're using the
delicate control on the dock box system
to be able to actually stop agitation on
a schedule every two hours for 10
minutes and then remove a small amount
of media and replenish it with with
fresh media and this is something that's
that's enabled by the fact that I PSE
grow in these larger aggregates so of
course when you turn off agitation the
aggregates will settle quite quickly
because they're quite heavy and then you
can easily take off some media and put
in some fresh media and by doing this
slowly over the course of the entire day
we get the same result as a nice
perfusion without having to use a cell
retention device or that have that extra
capital investment and we get even
better growth of the cells in this
format so you can see in the graph here
I just point out here that in this graph
you can see that the red and the black
bars show you the difference between the
Bosch / fed-batch that I showed you in
the past slide and then this perfusion
technique and you get quite a few more
viable cell density and the results of
being able to nice low and slow add
these nutrients to the cells as opposed
to bolus feeding them and possibly
shocking them in that way and then of
course we show you here all of the
information on the metabolites and the
analysis of what's going on inside the
tank lactate accumulation goes up over
time which you
expects glucose consumption occurs over
time which you expect and we have a nice
metabolic profile with which to analyze
these cells and to also provide data for
scale-up so we're able to get nice
expansion of these cells in the dosbox
in the 0.3 liter scale are we still able
to get these cells to express
pluripotency markers and the answer to
that question is yes again this data
here is a mix of data from the two last
from from our collaborator and from our
lab here in Connecticut so the panels
that I'm showing you on the top of the
slide here you can see phase contrast
right here which just shows the
morphology of the cells and suspension
cells here in this panel are expressing
the multi potency marker try 160 and
then also the pluripotency marker SSE a4
and of course we're using markers that
are not included in the reprogramming
cassette or Yamanaka factors so that we
can we can be sure that they are genomic
expression and not induced expression
and then this can also be done not just
by fluorescence microscopy but also by
flow cytometry what we're looking for
here is greater than 80 percent at this
stage over time these markers go right
back up into the high 90s but right
after the expansion we get 84 percent of
cells expressing trial 160 and then over
90 percent expressing s FDA 4 you can
see that in these flow cytometry graphs
here so even after being amplified in
stirred tank bioreactor format we do
still see expression of the pluripotency
markers and again that expression
actually gets even higher over time and
over a passage number in the bioreactor
so what have we talked about so far so
in conclusion I can say definitely that
HSC expansion although it is technically
demanding
is achievable in a scalable and robust
way using the BIOS blue single-use
special product line and in this work
we've adhered to the three critical
parameters that I outlined for you at
the beginning of the talk we're able to
achieve large cell numbers even over 1
billion hm SCS and upwards of four to
five fold IPSC expansion was achieved
and we're able to show that H MSC and
IPS e retain their pluripotency markers
and then third differentiation ability
we've also shown that MSDS grown in the
bioreactor do retain the ability to
differentiate into multiple cell types
and in fact I can tell you now that
since this presentation was made the age
i PS see differentiation has been done
and cells that were grown in the 0.3 C
can be differentiated into
cardiomyocytes and that data is
available for in publications from our
collaborators at Hanover medical school
the bio blue single-use vessel is
combination with a DOSBox mini
bioreactor or one of the bench scale
bioreactor systems is a powerful way to
establish your process and in fact it's
scalable that's probably one of the most
important points is that when you get
your process to work at the point three
liter scale you want to be able to make
more and the scalability of the bio
Bevacqua product line has been tried and
true and provides you with that extra
confidence when you're designing a
process that's all I have for you today
I hope the presentation was informative
and that you came up with lots of great
questions for me excellent presentation
dr. Willard thanks for bringing that
information to us before we get started
with all of your questions here's a
quick reminder about how to reach us
today questions can be sent via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll get to as
many as we can and our first is how do
you recommend testing the quality of the
IPS cells throughout the reprogramming
and expansion steps great question so
the way we do that here in our lab in
the US
we have a flow cytometry assay which
will allows us to look at expression of
SS CA for trot 160 and SSE a1 and we can
we've have it standardized to the point
where we can take a sample of the
bioreactor almost every other day or
every day if we want to and go through
this cell surface marker assay and then
look and see what percentage of the
population is still expressing these
markers and that's a really great way to
know whether they're starting to lose
their their multi potency and starting
to differentiate or not the other way of
course is just by morphology a lot of
times you can tell the cells start to
change shape and size and if you have a
one of these counting devices sometimes
you can see that the populations start
to drift over time just based on looking
at cell counts can you deduce these for
organoid culture with me for gel in
suspension we haven't done that in house
here at Eppendorf but there are a lot of
people in the field developing that
right now and I was just looking into
some of the literature recently so
there's a lot of promising research but
nothing that I can present data from
here today the next one has a couple
parts let me know if I need to remind
how you recover MSU cells from the micro
carriers what was the recovery
efficiency and what reagents were used
okay that's that's okay all those those
those parts are related so I think I can
remember them all so when we did add MSC
culture and bio blue 5c vessel we
recovered the cells just using a
standard trypsin digestion and our cells
were over 90 percent viable we didn't
have any issues with that we were very
successful it did take a little bit of
troubleshooting of course as to how long
to leave the cells in trypsin but that
was quite successful for us I've heard
of some other groups using other types
of disassociation reagents in case the
trypsin is too harsh for your particular
cell line as I mentioned before your
cell line has a lot to do with how you
will treat it so people have tried
things like triple people have tried a
queue taste and some of these other more
gentle disassociation methods for also
removing the cells from the micro
carrier the next question references
slide 32 what was the time duration
scheduled for meteor removal in addition
I can see the spike is for once a day
but I think you mentioned that it is
every two hours we go back to slide 32
so I can make sure I'm talking about
what we're what I hope we are can we see
any thing you need to repeat the
question okay so here we are on slide 32
and yes I see I see your point
so this slide was actually from I mean
perfusion information is in the black
line on this slide on the glucose
profile and it's actually being compared
to the batch profile in red so that's
why the batch profile looks like it goes
up and down in glucose here and this in
the red here that's actually the batch
data and you can see the black line
under it that just kind of like goes
down slowly over time
that's the perfusion data you're right
it was the media was removed every two
hours for 10 minutes at all time and
then a seven milliliter replenishment so
you can find all the details for that in
the publication that we're referencing
here on this slide it's a very nice
material of the method section there
great about saying well exactly how they
did it so feel free to reference that in
the shaker versus spinner eval with that
evaluation what was the size of the
spinner flask and agitation rate used of
the spinner flask that we compared to oh
my goodness you got me that's a detail
that I haven't thought about in a while
and you might have me on that one I I'll
have to get back to them on that if they
like to send me an email
I'd be happy to send that information or
they can go ahead and I don't know if
you notice but right on the actual slide
was a reference to the paper that it
came from
here is that is that up now you can see
in the bio processing Journal there was
a cover article which was basically the
establishment of this method and we're
happy to send you that reference where
it shows all of our materials and
methods on that sorry I can't remember
the RPM off the top of my head hey did
you observe aspiration of micro carriers
when doing a fed batch media change in
the 5c centigrade bio blue system and
how can this be prevented good question
so we did not see much aspiration there
of course will be a few micro carrier
that gets sucked up it's kind of like
how the method is but it was very
minimal in this experiment we allowed
the micro carrier to settle down in the
vessel for about 20 minutes or so and
then we very slowly pumped off 50% of
the vessel volume and then slowly added
it back in so there was not as much of
an issue with micro carrier loss because
the sample tube that we're using to
remove my media was far enough away from
the layer of micro carrier at the bottom
of the vessel that we didn't lose very
many what do you mean by the IPS C's
increased by fourfold is it four-fold
increase per mil of media used it's
fourfold over inoculation volume or
inoculation density sorry that was my
fault okay great and pause okay next one
is what would be so retention device
used for perfusion so as I let me see if
I can call that slide back up again and
I'll tell you a little bit about how
they did it back at slide 32 here so
what they did is they have a point 3 C
which is the cell culture version of our
single-use vessel and they stopped
agitation every two hours and then allow
the
the micro care are the aggregates to
settle to the bottom then they just use
a dip tube that's not all the way down
to the bottom of the vessel remove part
of the media and then replace it so that
that's how that was done and it can be
automated very nicely in the software as
well so they didn't have to be there at
the bioreactor every two hours they
didn't need a retention device either
because since the aggregator agregate
sorry the aggregates are heavy enough
they settle down to the bottom just like
a micro carrier would so the aggregates
themselves slide down to the bottom by
gravity you remove the media replace it
it's quite easy wait how did you get the
cells off the micro carriers so that was
one that we we at we answered a little
bit before but I can tell you again the
our method was by trypsin disassociation
but other people have used other types
of disaggregation methods in the past
more gentle reagents as well why did you
use different sources of micro carriers
in the different experiments well that's
a good question so as I said quite a few
times I'm sorry if I'm a broken record
at this point but every single cell line
has their own personality and their own
optimization that's required and so what
we found in our hands for the adipose
derived his ankle stem cells was that we
did not get very high expansion unless
we went into a college and coded micro
carrier so we tried a few different
manufacturers and we got the best
amplification of those cells using the
collagen coded Paul micro carriers our
group in Belgium got better
amplification of cells using micro
carrier from another source and GE in
fact decided X product line so it all
depends on the cell line and it all
depends on which so which micro carrier
surface your cells prefer I'd like to
thank the at candy's for those great
questions if we didn't get to yours we
will follow up with you via email
and also please note the slides will be
available for download I would also like
to once again thank dr. Stacy Willard
for her presentation do you have any
final comments I would just like to
thank everybody for tuning in and for
everybody who's going to listen to the
recording after I hope we've provided
some confidence in the bio blue product
line for stem cell expansion and we're
happy to talk to you about it further
thank you
we also like to thank our sponsor
Eppendorf for making it possible to
bring this presentation to you this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
Cee button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June 6 2017 you'll receive an email from
us alerting you when it's available on
demand and posted on lab routes com
you're welcome to forward this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time